je vous remercie la maire de saint
médard de guizières mireille contre
jaubert d'être avec nous ce soir merci
merci madame la mairesse
voilà merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
venus de gironde ex-ps répondre et c'est
vrai que cette histoire on n'a parlé que
de vous depuis ce week-end hier on a eu
le témoignage de shirley alors on va
revenir sur cette affaire qui a fait
énormément réagir il ya beaucoup de gens
qui nous ont dit on aimerait aussi avoir
la version de la mère et enfin la
mairesse vous me dire la mairesse et la
mer en scène on va pas s'en sortir et
donc c'est vrai que c'est une affaire
qui a énormément fait réagir la scène
s'est passée la semaine dernière dans un
petit village de gironde si vous n'étiez
pas dans l'émission hier un enfant de 7
ans était raccompagné chez lui par la
police pour pas là pour l'empêcher de
manger à la cantine alors la mairie
avait pris cette décision à cause des
impayés des parents qui devaient environ
1600 900 euros de cantine alors ça c'est
la version qu'on avait on va voir si
c'est la vraie version avec la la
mairesse hier charles et la maman est en
plateau avec nous pour témoigner les
revenus bien sûr sur l'humiliation de
son fils et ça c'est sûr que voilà ça on
va revenir dessus c'est indéniable et
aujourd'hui on va vous donner votre
droit de réponse on va revoir ce caniche
sur les yeah sur son fils regarde qu'est
ce qui s'est passé donc il au milieu de
la cour votre fils ouidane c'est qui qui
vient le chercher là plus proviseur de
l'école et je n'étais pas moins fort
mais c'est venu dans le vin le policier
est venu d'en lancer jeu apparemment
c'est comme ça que sa saison qu'ils ont
vu donc ses potes ont vu votre fils
partir avec le policier tous les petits
coups expliqué on s'étend donc en soi
c'est normal c'est de leur arracher en
prison en prison mettez les sirènes
voilà c'est très traumatisant pau puis
pour ses pattes ces histoires comment il
a vécu will and co qu'est ce qui vous a
dit willan il était vraiment il est
rentré vous explique tout vent s'est
moqué de moi on m'a déjà là l'an prison
gillan tu n'as rien fait ce n'est pas ta
faute l'histoire elle part de moi à la
base ça tu es pas fautif c'est pas grave
alors myrick contre jaubert merci d'être
là c'est vrai que quand on voit ça c'est
vrai qu'on a tous été vraiment très
triste pour ce jeune homme ce jeune
petit de 7 ans et je cours je pense que
vous aussi forcément qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est quoi votre version des faits
alors là la version des faits de la
maman sur le principe qu'elle doit de
l'argent bien sûr c'est indéniable mais
en ce qui concerne la le fait qu'on soit
allé chercher
son fils à la cantine ça c'est pas du
tout passé comme il le dit à aucun
moment ça n'a été traumatisant pour
l'enfant parce qu'on lui a raconté une
histoire en fait on lui a dit que sa
maman avait oublié de dire qu'ils ne
mangeaient pas à la cantine et que comme
elle connaissait le policier municipal
qui assurent la sécurité des enfants à
midi le soir et le matin à la rentrée
elle lui avait demandé de
le ramener chez elle c'était un mensonge
certes un mensonge utile pour que
l'enfant ne soit pas traumatisé et
l'enfant est monté dans la voiture très
content parce qu'il montait dans une
voiture de police comme il serait monté
dans une voiture de pompier ses petits
copains l'envié d'être dans une vraie
voiture de police donc aujourd'hui
l'enfant il n'a pas été traumatisé par
ce qu'on a fait mais il est traumatisé
par tout ce que sa maman a fait depuis
parce qu'on n'a jamais dit à cet enfant
qu'il que sa maman avait une dette de
cantine il est monté dans la voiture
très confiant parce qu'en plus il
connaît le policier municipal depuis
plus d'un an mais juste les autres en
forêt ouais je suis la vérité un moment
ah ben il apparaît maintenant vu
l'ampleur médiatique que ça a pris
jusqu'à présent personne ne savait que
sa maman avait une dette de cantine
aujourd'hui le monde entier sait qu'elle
a une dette de cantine donc forcément
les petits copains forcément les mamans
et les papas des autres enfants mais
nous on n'a pas traumatisé cet enfant
maintenant madame ma mère est juste le
problème on va pas se mentir ça a été
une décision compliquée à prendre pour
vous il n'a rien à voir le petit
repartirait pas manger à la cantine
c'est un crève coeur pour la directrice
de l'école c'est toujours un crève coeur
de prendre ce type de décision mais à un
moment j'avais eu la maman auparavant
alors il paraît que ça s'était mal passé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec qu'est ce
qui s'est passé je j'avais je lui avait
adressé un courrier comme j'ai adressé
un courrier à toutes les parents qui
avaient des dettes de cantine et ce en à
peu près 60 pour un montant total de 17
mille euros ce qui est énorme pour une
petite collectivité
donc j'avais adressé à peu près une
semaine avant un courrier en demandant
aux parents de régulariser leur
situation on leur met pas le couteau sur
la gorge on leur demande de prendre
contact avec le trésor public pour
convenir d'un échéancier donc sinon ils
ne pourraient pas avoir accès au service
de la cantine et aux services
périscolaires
donc elle était elle a été destinataire
de ce courrier comme les autres parents
et là elle m'a appelé en me disant que
je n'avais pas le droit
d'empêcher l'enfant de manger à la
cantine que c'était un scandale elle
s'est montrée menaçante
je lui ai demandé donc je lui ai dit
qu'elle devait quand même je crois à 873
euros et elle m'a dit de toutes les
façons si vous n'acceptez pas mon enfant
à la cantine je ne paierai pas l'aimer
173 euros donc je lui ai dit écoutez non
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe vous
payez votre dette et je reprendrai votre
enfant à la cantine mais allez voir le
trésor public pour convenir d'un
échéancier on ne demande pas qu'elle
paie 873 euros tout de suite ça se fait
pas ça se voit pas et là où l'avait fier
de vous lui avez fait des relances ou
parce qu'elle a dit qu'elle avait eu
aucune relance c'est les gens qui ont
des dettes qui n'ont jamais de relance
qui n'ont jamais de facturer qui l'ont
jamais relance donc elle a eu des
relances comme tout le monde
il a eu des invitations à des
rendez-vous à la mairie pour essayer de
trouver une solution ensemble elle est
venue une fois en avril nous remettre un
rib mais qu'ils ne pouvaient pas être
utilisées pour les dettes antérieures ce
qu'elle nous a dit trésor public qui a
choqué vous a remis un rival a dit que
vous aviez vous l'aviez pas utilisé bah
si on l'a utilisé le premier prélèvement
qu'on a fait il a été rejeté un bal
d'accord d'accord donc si si on l'a
utilisé je vous assure que quand il
s'agit de faire rentrer de l'argent on
utilise les rib surtout quand on a une
dette aussi importante weekly moi j'ai
une question pour le petit surtout parce
qu'on pense beaucoup au petit est ce que
vous avez eu l'idée d'appeler la police
ou est ce que c'est parce que vous
connaissiez le policier qui l'a ramené
le petit passe comment un jour ma mère a
oublié de venir me chercher à la cantine
elle pensait que j manger bon bah c'est
une voisine qui m'a ramené chez moi et
ça aurait pu empêcher ce grabuge et et
tout ce truc au père de deux enfants et
ça c'est parce que vous connaissez le
policier ou es ce que vous avez la
démarche d'appeler la police pas du tout
c'est une démarche réglementaire et jeu
long a expliqué la réglementation j'ai
travaillé ensemble mais non c'est notre
policier municipal d'accord qui il était
à l'essai la réglementation on doit
ramener l'enfant par la police on doit
ramener jeu personnes de la commune ne
peut ramener l'enfant et on ne peut
surtout pas demander un parent qui est
inscrit sur la liste des parents la coop
a récupéré des enfants on ne peut pas
donc on a on sait le policier municipal
je veux dire j'avais plusieurs solutions
effectivement la meilleure c'était que
l'enfant mange à la cantine
on restait dans le même cycle il paraît
que vous avez une altercation avec la
maman est vrai que vous l'avez raccroché
au nez ce qu'elle nous a dit qu'après il
y avait plus une nouvelle ne veut pas
il ya plus une nouvelle de ma part alors
là pourquoi il fallait je lui téléphone
pour la romaine pour la primaire car le
voilà lancé elle aurait aimé que vous
l'après veniez que son fils allait
rentrer voilà chez elle voilà je n'ai
pas la prévenue qu'elle ne devait pas
inscrire l'enfant à la cantina tu veux
dire aujourd'hui c'est la collectivité
qui supporte la charge des impayés et
des gens qui sont malveillants donc à un
moment tous les toutes les autres
personnes qui ont qui avaient des dettes
et quittions qui ont reçu la même
lettres qu'elles ont trouvé des
arrangements pour régulariser leur
situation
dans le temps j'ai pas dit que les 873
euros devait être réglé demain et ils
pouvaient être réglés sur 12 mois sur 14
mois et en plus cette maman si elle
avait des difficultés il fallait
qu'elles viennent nous voir
je n'avais jamais entendu parler d'elle
avant je ne savais pas qui c'était on a
un ccas on a un service social qui
fonctionne très bien je n'avais jamais
eu connaissance de difficultés de la
part de cette famille donc pour moi elle
n'avait aucune raison de ne pas payer sa
dette et pour moi c'est de la mauvaise
foi voilà notamment castaldi mais j'ai
peut être quelqu'un d'autre que le
policier a parmi nous ici
faire appel à des gens de croupir les
services à l'annoncé du jugement vous
avez raison j'ai pu faire appel aux
services d'urgence et les pires verte
est beaucoup plus traumatisant moi je
pose la question parce que entre le
policier et la police ni quelqu'un de
béthune en manque des éléments c'est
celui que vous occupez j'ai fait une
traversée
fait traverser de vrais que vrais gones
et de bacon maintenant dans une commune
dans une commune la police municipale et
dans la mairie rejet rallye à un ou deux
policiers
c'est qu'il a c'est l'élu local qui
parle non il faut que ce que d'un petit
peu je très content le koleos est très
content qu'on ait reçu madame
aujourd'hui et qu'on l'écouté quand même
parce que pardon hier je parle pas pour
moi je m'en fous je me suis fait
insulter c'est pas la première fois mais
tout d'un coup rejet de mapala dernier
je remercie mais tout d'un coup on a une
autre version on a une femme qui n'a pas
payé qui n'a pas voulu trouver un
arrangement qui n'a pas ouvert son
courrier qui a menacé en plus de dire
derrière eh ben il ira quand même sinon
de toute manière je paierai pas si vous
voulez publier soi et qui vient ensuite
se plaindre à la télévision pardon c'est
tout
on est et rouge des solutions adaptées à
tous les besoins sur quatre tu crois que
c'est une fierté pour ça bien sûr je
crois de cartes et une quelconque fierté
de dire je n'ai pas les moyens de payer
sur 12 mois chez vous au lieu de l'aider
à partir et qu'il a gentiment idée
c'était la seule chose à faire vous
l'infantiliser vous la jugez en me
disant mais madame vous enfants vont à
l'école privée et madame vous vous laver
les cheveux mais madame scénario du
sénat n'a jamais problèmes d'argent
franchement tu appelles les gens nés
gabon on trouve surtout il ya 14 mois
que très rarement mis en mission en
france où la cantine est gratuite déjà
donc il faut aider les gens qui ont des
seins
quand je pense pas qu'elle en tire une
quelconque fierté parce qu'on vient
reste avec sa qui a dit ça [ __ ] mais
tu es né des majeurs la télé avec sa
plainte elle a médiatisé la ferme oui si
l'on se pose aujourd'hui est ce que la
cantine doit être gratuite pour tous les
enfants où tout le monde paie ou
personne savait mais il n'y a pas de
raison qu'il y ait des gens qui
s'affranchissent de ceux de leurs dettes
et là en l'occurrence on lit peau comme
vous disiez on lui proposer un
arrangement
elle pouvait très bien très bien essayer
de trouver une solution je vais vous
dire moi j'ai quelqu'un dans la commune
qui est en grande difficulté malade est
en grande difficulté c'était un huissier
qui passait son temps à les lui réclamer
de l'argent la commune a payé les 2008
146 euros de dettes de cette famille je
veux dire je je
si elle avait été en grande difficulté
elle venait nous voir elle fait pas
l'autruche canada madame la main juste
quelques fois que ça ça va être quoi la
suite maintenant alors donc la comptine
a été réglé c'est bon puis je sais pas
s'il a sonné jeudi après le débat où il
s'en va là on va larguer en fait la
comptine bokova alors moi je vais vous
dire je suis très contente que vous
réguliers la cantina vous voulez vous
des règles pour vous aussi voulez un an
mais j'aimerais bien que vous le fassiez
pour les autres parents qui eux se sont
décarcassés allons nous retrouver
solutions éculées lors du je vais vous
dire qu'ils sont bons je serais contre
défi culte et qu'elle je vais vous dire
même y venir ce qui s'est passé moi je
sais surtout pensé aux petits airs et
obtient là je voulais que ce histoire
sur un wagon qui doit il a été hier
qu'il aille à la cantine et que
l'histoire serait il arrivé que cette
affaire et qu'ils puissent aller manger
tranquillement et retrouver ses petits
copains parce qu'il n'a rien à voir là
dedans le pauvre et voilà c'est surtout
pour ça non mais c'est vrai aussi je le
veux mais tu roules un entretien
en a pour dix sept mille balta cas est
réglé
[Rires]
seibert l'important c'est que tu as la
cantine merci me raconte jaubert d'avoir
été avec nous et merci de nous expliquer